we live encompassing everything that's
on our land now the animals the plants
the mountains the water and they
violated every single portion of that
and thereby violated our way of life
what do you do when your home is divided
by a border well that's the dilemma of
the Tohono automation or desert people
they're four thousand square mile
reservation is sliced by the us-mexico
border and with more and more
militarization Border Patrol are a
constant presence any movement that we
made if we go pick the saguaro cactus
fruit we have to show our tribal ID that
were not undocumented people so you
don't feel that you're being kept safe
from migrants coming across the border I
have never been threatened by a migrant
this migration of people's globally it's
a natural occurring thing these borders
are arbitrary borders political borders
this is what happens when you come over
here the Border Patrol show up to see
what we're doing but they don't want to
be on camera
there's no big wall or fence along the
border of the reservation and the autumn
people can walk across here at will
that's part of the complication for
Border Patrol it's an easier place to
cross than others along the us-mexico
border but the autumn aren't just caught
up in America's war on illegal
immigration but its war on drugs too
every year hundreds of thousands of
pounds of marijuana are trafficked
through this region and some autumn with
no other economic opportunities take
part in it if young people see cars they
want a car they want to take their
elders to the store on their own you
know they'll run that drugs just till
they can get money because there's no
jobs out here tribal member Mike Flores
says that has made the entire nation a
target you guys know who these guys are
why don't you go and arrest them or deal
with them directly instead of netting
all of us with you know one one
particular individual you know we're not
all in that same group of the smuggling
everybody here in the community as a
suspect according to them now the
government wants to watch Tohono autumn
territory even more closely the
Department of Homeland Security has
proposed building 15 towers along the
border some propped on top of mountains
the autumn consider sacred the company
to do it is the Israeli elbit systems
the very same one that helped build the
wall in the West Bank this you notice
the international border goes along here
which is not even near any of these
proposed towers we're under surveillance
almost 24 hours a day if not people on
the ground it's you know things up in
the air you know that are monitoring our
movements o philia says Border Patrol
should work with the autumn people to
come up with solutions rather than
handing them down if the Border Patrol
came here and told me we want to work
with you the best way that we can so
that we don't not interrupt your way of
life
we do not build towers on top of human
remains how can we work together this
has never happened